长话短说话，
第一个呢，
就是我现在在上海，
然后我明年的话是30岁，
然后我现在我一直是做销售嘛，
然后自己也攒了一点钱，
但是我现在很迷茫的就是我们现在这个行业不太好，
然后我可能想着明年回老家，
但是我现在没什么学历，
也没什么技能，
我在想我自己要学点什么东西，
你帮我建议一下，
原来自己是什么专业呀，
我原来就是没什么学历，
高中毕业，
然后在就很早就出来了，
然后自己有成一的这样子了，
你那个职业，
比如说你这高中毕业差不多十几岁啊，
十七八岁到现在是你这十多年你都干过哪些呢？
就是做销售，
就一直在做销售啊，
销售的是哪些产品呢？
房产啊，
销售的是房产，
你现在大概攒了多少存款呀？
呃，
有个一两百吧，
哇，
你好棒哦，
太棒了，
姑娘没有，
但是就是因为那个时候就是封口嘛，
然后但现在就是特别不好，
所以想着就是明年要回家，
但是就是因为没什么技能嘛，
所以就是非常的焦虑，
那你现在嗯，
有对象嘛，
有过一个分手了，
然后也单身，
所以这个也很焦虑，
那你自己从小长大的过程当中，
有没有什么兴趣爱好啊，
喜欢干啥呀，
我觉得我可能就是适应能力比较强吧，
然后抗压能力比较强，
干啥都行，
是这意思不对，
那你同学朋友当中有没有谁就是干哪个行业，
现在跟你关系也不错，
他干的也挺好的呢，
包括家里面的亲戚啊，
对吧，
家里面亲戚有没有谁，
你关系跟他还行，
然后他干的那个事儿干的挺好的，
现在有有有朋友就是做这个直播，
然后做的还挺不错的啊，
他做直播是做带货主播还是颜值主播，
还是什么主播呢？
带货主播他卖鞋子好像在莆田那边卖的还不错，
那我觉得你应该去找找他，
如果说你跟他关系还不错的话，
你去找找他，
关系也没有特别好，
但是就是嗯，
也可以走，
在你本人是有能力的情况下，
咱不说别的啊，
假设你真的想学。
这个的话你都可以免费给他打三个月的工，
你本身就是做销售的是吧，
其实就是把你线线下的那个销售能力给他转换到线上来，
他这个因为他做的比较早，
然后他自己会剪辑什么的，
然后这两年的话，
大环境不是特别好嘛，
因为那个，
然后也我也有亲戚工也跟着他，
他做，
然后好像就是做了一年多，
现在也不怎么样，
其实如果你自己是属于那种销售能力比较强，
且学习能力比较强的人的话，
或许你比他做的好，
你知道吧，
因为你现在你千万，
你现在手上这200万的存款，
千万别着急买房，
你去搞什么投资啊什么的，
你现在要做的就是零成本，
零成本去学习一下。
好行，
所以这个东西是值得值得学习一下的，
我还要可以学点什么其他技能之类的，
因为我现在在上场嘛，
剪辑啊剪辑，
你要搞网络搞直播的话，
你肯定自己得学点剪辑是吧，
好的，
还有一个问题，
就是我之前那个前任，
然后他欠我钱，
然后欠我几万，
然后我打官司已经胜诉了，
然后现在是在强制执行期，
然后到明年三月份就满了，
他确实好像没什么钱，
然后我这个还要做什么吗？
而且就这样他申请他上黑名单是那形式吗？
已经上黑名单了是吧？
对，
明年就三四月份就满两年了哦，
已经上黑名单了的话，
那这个事儿就放在那儿，
他什么时候他不想在黑名单里面待着了，
他就得还你的钱，
但是我好像听说就是如果就是强制执行2年之后，
他还没有名下没有存款，
这个会取消对吗？
或者你还可以申请强制执行，
只要你钱没到位，
你还可以申请哦，
好的，
嗯，
还有一个就是因为现在毕竟这个年纪了，
然后家里就。
非常焦急，
很焦虑，
然后介绍的对象啊，
就是可能找不来，
我在想要不要，
就是万别因为家里面催，
因为焦虑就去凑合，
千万别让人家知道你有200万存款，
不要让任何人知道，
甚至不要让家里人知道你有那么多存款，
嗯，
好行，
还有你要多学一点那种大那个，
或是多学一点大案例，
我跟你讲哦，
女孩子哦，
自己手上有点存款啊，
你在这个社会上闯荡啊，
你就是一块肥肉，
你知道吗？
所以你不要跟任何一个人，
包括闺蜜，
包括将来的男朋友，
包括自己的亲人，
不要跟任何人说你手上有那么多存款，
我觉得这个钱也不是很多，
现在的状态就是非常非常焦虑，
挺多的啦，
一个女孩子哦，
30岁的年纪能有这么多存款，
你已经非常优秀了，
你现在人生当中最首要的任务是第一要保住这些存款，
不被任何人，
不管是基于感情也好，
基于亲情也好，
基于什么价也好，
不被任何人把你这钱搞走，
这是其一，
其二的话就是发挥自己已经有的这种优势，
你本来原来就是一直做销售的，
嗯，
对吧，
在销售这个领域的话，
你比如说那个朋友，
他做直播也是卖货，
也是那个什么的话，
多学明白，
就是这样啊，
谢，
嗯。
所有的姐妹啊，
你们没事的时候，
你们在抖音，
你就搜心诈骗，
你就多学多听多看，
他就会形成一种免疫，
就是你你看的多了之候，
突然有一天你接到那种骗电话，
你接到那种诈骗短信，
你遇到那种诈骗事儿的话，
你就会就好像是一个本能一样，
你说诶这个我见过对吧，
这个我听过，
这个我了解过，
就不容易上当受骗，
像你们龙飞姐的话我更绝，
我不接陌生电话，
你谁来骗我的钱啊，
不接陌生电话我也不占任何的便宜，
任何人我买了东西啊，
比如说我在任何地方买东西，
它里面不是有一个什么扫码就能，
嗯，
比如说评论啊什么的，
又能给你两块钱，
或者扫码了之后加了什么什么客服了之后，
又给你返多少钱，
我从来不要，
一毛都不要，
别想骗我的钱，
别想诈骗我的钱，
我不贪这个便宜，
任何时候管任何人给你寄什么东西啊，
里面有什么二维码又这那的让你扫码什么的啊，
尤其是要跟家里的老人一定要打好预防针，
不要轻易给人家扫码呀，
干嘛的啊，
刚刚有的朋友说没有房的话，
200万真不多，
我不跟他说了吗？
让他不要轻易买房，
就找对象呗，
找对象就奔着有房的找呗，
这样你不就不用买房了吗？
那你这200万存款你呃单独存到一张卡里。
那你婚后赚的钱不要跟这200万存款放在一起，
那么这200万存款她就是永远都是你婚前的个人财产，
你跟谁分手，
她都分不着这200万，
明白吗？
一个女人哦，
你有200万的存款啊，
你多从容啊，
是吧，
很从容的呀，
你不管跟谁在一起的时候，
都会有一个退路呀，
她跟我好好过，
她对我好，
我就好好跟他过，
她敢打我，
她敢骂我，
她敢羞辱我，
她敢践踏我的尊严，
老娘有200万，
我分分钟我拎包走了。